up to now we've talked about
resistors and capacitors and other
components and we've connected them up
and learned about ohm's law for
resistors and we also we've learned some
things about series resistors like we
show here
the idea of kirkhof's laws these are
basically common sense
laws that we can derive from looking at
simple circuits and in this video we're
gonna
we're gonna work out
kirkhof's current law
let's take a look at these series
resistors here there's a connection
point right there
and that's called a node a junction
and one of the things we know
is that when we put current through this
let's say we put a current through here
and we know that current is flowing
charge so we know that the charge does
not collect anywhere so that means it
comes out
of this resistor and flows into the node
and then goes across
and it comes out on this side all the
current that comes in
comes out
that's something we know that's the
conservation of charge and we know that
the charge does not pile up anywhere
we'll call this current i1
and we'll call this current i2
and we know we can just write right away
i1
equals i2
that's that seems pretty clear from our
argument about about charge
now let me add something else here we'll
add another resistor to our node
like that
and this now there's going to be some
current going this way let's call that
i3
and now this doesn't work anymore this
i1 and i2 are not necessarily the same
but what we do know is any current that
goes in has to come out of this node so
we can say that i1 equals i2
plus i3
that seems pretty reasonable and in
general what we have here is
if we take all the current flowing in it
equals
all the current flowing out
and that's that's kirchhoff's current
law that's a one way to say it in in
mathematical notation we would say
i in
the summation of currents going in
this the summation sign
is the summation
of i out
that's one expression of kirchhoff's
current law
so now i want to generalize i want to
generalize this a little bit
let's uh let's say we have a node and we
have some wires going into it
here's some wires connected up to a node
and there's current going into each one
i'm going to define the current arrows
this this looks a little odd but it's
okay to do
all going in
and what kirchhoff's current law says
is that the sum
of the currents
going into that node has to be equal to
zero
let's let's work out how that works
let's say this is one amp
and this is one amp and this is
one amp
and the question is what is this one
what's that current there
if i use my kirchhoff's current law
expressed this way
it says that 1 plus 1 plus 1
plus i whatever
this i here
has to equal 0.
and what that says is that i equals
minus
three
so that says minus three amps flowing in
is the same exact thing as plus three
amps flowing out
so one amp one amp one amp comes in
three amperes flows out
another way we could do it
equally valid this is just three ways to
say exactly the same thing i have
a bunch of wires going to a junction
like this
and this time i define the currents
going out let's say i define them all
going out
and the same thing works some of the
currents
this time going out
i'll go back over here i'll write in all
the currents going in
that has to equal zero as well
and you can do the same exercise if i
make all these one amp
and ask what is this what is this one
here what is i here
outgoing current it's one plus one
plus one
plus one those are the four that i know
and those are the ones going out
so what's the last one going out it has
to equal zero the last one has to be
minus
four
equals zero
so this is a current of
minus four
amperes so that's the idea of
kirchhoff's current law it's basically
we reason through it from first
principles
because
everything that comes in has to leave by
some route and when we talked about it
that way we ended up with this
expression for kirchhoff's current law
and we can come up with a slightly
smaller mathematical expression if we
say let's
define all the currents to be pointing
in some of them may turn out to be
negative but then that's another way
to write kirchhoff's current law
and in the same way if we define all the
currents going out and you actually have
your choice of any of these three
anytime you want to use these if we find
them all going out
this is
kirchhoff's current law
and we'll use this all the time when we
do circuit analysis